yeah dude oh [ __ ] good enough oh [ __ ]
we're in trouble will and chad you are
both huge fans of the band pearl jam not
really i mean they're okay but
you album 10 was released on august 27
1991.
i have supplied you with a list of
events that the human race found to be
significant in that year
use this astonishing list to describe
these events in the style of various
pearl jam songs this is pearl jammin
begin okay that's interesting this is in
your dude it does have a soul dude
dudes he loves pearl jam just so we're
going to come up with
we're going to jam out some
pearl jam 10. [ __ ] dude look at this
list gulf war street fighter 2
dude street fighter 2's got a yeah at
home
no it was the arcade version
yeah it came out in 91 dude my god damn
i don't know how much time i spent
playing that [ __ ] game that was a
[ __ ] awesome game uh
so you wouldn't be at home no we went to
[ __ ] 7-eleven we went to [ __ ]
there was a grocery store called
vineyards that we would go to vineyards
miniatures you know street vineyards we
had uh we had uh i believe i mentioned
this on a previous episode we had
heritage queue that was a little
overwhelming arcade lots of pool tables
and again some [ __ ] bangers over
there we call them bangers metal heads
nice dude if you want to get your ass
kicked but first get some fries and
gravy um then get your ass kicked with a
full stomach so you can lay there in the
sun and uh digest
but um there was also cky there was a
place not to be confused with uh bam
margera's brother's band we had a
corner store called cky uh
uh uh uh
uh at
at the corner store
with my
corner store with my buddies
water on the glass
that means i'm next to play street
fighter 2
eight players to choose from
uh at corner store with my brothers
corner store with my buddies
quarter on the gas go grab it wait
rip a little stroke
corner store with my buddies quarter on
the glass
that means i'm next to play street
fighter 2
there was eight characters yeah and
characters to choose from
but we only play with can and right
[Music]
[Laughter]
and sometimes i'd play blanca
he could roll into a ball and shoot
electricity
and that's hard to beat
street fighter 2 is
my favorite game to play
street fighter
my favorite game to play
oh once in a while you used chun li
or dal team
andy honda was a big fat [ __ ]
but he still had those abs and beat the
[ __ ] out of a honda civic at the side of
the beach here
[Laughter]
i never used gal or [ __ ] uh zenke no
[Laughter]
did the helicopter kick
the [ __ ] out of blanco or anyone who
jumped up in the air
if you block my hadoo can i use
i use gail to throw that [ __ ] weird
thing
sonic boom street fighter 2 is
my favorite game to play
street thank you moving on
whatever
i don't get it yeah that was kind of fun
oh dude
it's my favorite game to play
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then